my name is Alexander rose on the
executive director here at the long now
foundation I'm really happy to have Lois
back here he's actually one of the first
speakers that we had here at logging is
one who got us in trouble with the fire
marshal actually and now we have to set
a hard limit on the room it was because
of his first talk his book the knowledge
which was a very synchronous book to to
us starting the interval here before we
started I had written this blog post
called the manual for civilization about
you know what would you do if you wanted
to write a manual for rebuilding
civilization and and and after I wrote
that he contacted me based on some work
he was doing with reading James Lovelock
original essay I believe right that was
that was around this topic and so we
kind of traded emails around this
collection which eventually became our
attempt to build about 3,000 books that
would help you preserve or restore
civilization and he went on to write the
300 page version which in a way is kind
of the index to this collection it's a
little window into every one of the
subjects that we hope to have a you know
a few books about but it was it was
amazing and we've been in touch ever
since and when I saw this book the
origins I was I was amazed at how
different it was from the first one but
at how even more sweeping in time-space
than then his knowledge book and if some
of you were at the Marcia Buner would
talk around her book time fulness
written from a geologists perspective
looking at this topic of how geology
changed humanity and then I think of
kind of a very different perspective
looking at it from outside the geology
field how geology affected humanity is
what Lewis is going to speak on tonight
and thank you very much for coming
good evening and thank you all very much
for coming along tonight my name is
Louis as you heard I'm a professor from
the other side of the pond in London at
the University of Westminster and the
field of my research that the my day job
if you like is in astrobiology and
helping in a hunt for life on other
planets I get paid a salary to look a
lian's specifically on Mars and not just
how could bacteria survive the
environmental conditions on the surface
of Mars but more important how we could
find they are there how can you build an
experiment to look for the signatures of
life to strap on the front of a Mars
rover and and test handfuls of Martian
dirt which is something both NASA and
the east of the European Space Agency
will be doing next year with two rovers
twin rovers that being launched next
year that that's my day job and
alongside that academic research as
you've heard I'd take a lot of enjoyment
about writing books the last one that I
was speaking I think three four years
ago almost of the day here in the
interval was on the knowledge this this
conceit as to how he could write a
manual for rebooting civilization as
quickly as possible after someone has
accidentally pushed the wrong red button
on his white I was desk and did in fact
get Diet Coke but ordered up the nuclear
Armageddon how could you accelerate the
progress through history as quickly as
possible
the second time round what is the most
important scientific knowledge do you
hope would never get lost again in the
dark ages and the most important
inventions and technology and tools you
would need to remake everything we have
in the world around us so hopefully you
you're on the same side than you realize
I'm not really talking about the end of
the world I'm not some kind of proper or
survivalist I'm a scientist who's
interested in the grand history of human
civilization and how we built the modern
world around us all the stuff that we
take for granted
it and everyday lives and what I've
tried to do with this new book with
origins is pull out on that focus on
that zoom even further and look at not
just how human ingenuity and discoveries
and inventions have built the world
around us but how the planet itself the
world we live on has had this
determining guiding influence on the
whole of the human story right from our
very beginnings are our very origins as
a species what was it about the
environment in East Africa that crafted
such an exquisitely adaptable and
intelligent species of Homo sapiens and
then through the thousands of years of
the history of the rise and fall of
civilizations and empires and the
building the modern nations how of
different features of the planet of
plate tectonics or the distribution of
different natural resources or the
circulation of the atmosphere directed
that story even up to the modern day of
current affairs and things you read
about in the newspaper or watch on the
breakfast news show or help people vote
how is politics even that as the
planetary influence beneath it so in
this new book and origins I've tried to
pull together all those different
threads combining planetary science and
the grand course of human history so
look at those deep connections
underlying the world we live in today
and how we got here
I wouldn't say kind of 5 million years
ago and what I wanted to do tonight is
pick out just a couple of those
narratives it turns out they're trying
to write a book on the whole of human
history and also the history of entire
planet who has quite a lot to bite off
and my editor tottered to me when I
submitted the first draft so for 45
minutes or so now I want to pull out
some of those interesting stories and
explain those connections between
features of our world and human history
I'm going to layer lots of maps on top
of each other and I think we should
probably start
at the beginning in the origins of us as
a species and this is our family tree on
a left here this is the hominin clade
this is not just honey sapiens at the
bottom but all of the other human-like
species or the hominin species reaching
back to our original divergence from the
chimpanzees about 6 or 7 million years
ago and over that course of evolutionary
history we've been transformed from
hairy tree swinging ape-like creatures
to naked hairless bipedal upright
walking and then very efficient upright
running creatures and we've also
witnessed these huge jumps in cranial
capacity effective er braininess our
intelligence for the entire hominin
evolutionary tree and alongside all
those changes to our bodies we've also
witnessed this story of the evolution of
human technology Stone Age tools going
from the very bottom here this predates
the origin of our species by about two
million years and you can almost almost
literally imagine some Homo erectus
trudging his or her way across the
plains of East Africa stubbing their toe
on this rock and going ugh which is a
very naughty Homo erectus swearword
clicking up that rock and then having
that first glimmer of introspection
realization is thing which you can stop
your toe on is actually quite useful to
bash things with it's a tool and then
over time we realize we could modify and
adapt those to be even better at the
jobs we wanted by chipping off flakes
around the outside to make sharpened
hand axes before we then realize that
actually the chips that you flake off
the coarse stone or even more useful
these are now very very fine and light
and incredibly sharp and pointy and
could be used as the tips for projectile
weapons for Spears and then arrows and
all of this human story the the
evolution of our of our species and our
technological
progression the original Silicon Valley
of these silicon tools was the East
African Rift Valley this is the cradle
of humanity here is where we grew up as
a species this internet new I also spent
my own childhood growing up in Nairobi
and Kenya I went to school called at the
banda which is swahili for mud hut I
went to the mud hut school in Nairobi
and had many pleasant memories spending
weekends and holidays in the savanna of
this environment and taking safaris down
into the Rift Valley and so
fundamentally what had to happen in this
region of the world where we were
our ancestors were was you had to
transform forests to change our tree
swinging ancestors into grassland into
savanna and if we zoom out from this
zoom in to look at our planet as a whole
if you just allow your eyes to swing
across the mid rift of the earth the
equator you'll realize that these along
the equators where all of the
rainforests of the planet found
Amazon the rainforests of Central Africa
the Congo and the forest smothering the
archipelago of islands of the East
Indies this is where Ronnie equator gets
very warm with a sunshine it rises
precipitates all that moisture to fall
back as rain and feeds waters these huge
rain forests the equator is rainforest
all apart from this weird dry little
corner of East Africa where we were what
dried out the region we were living in
and to answer that question we need to
peel off the satellite map of East
Africa and look at the terrain
topography of the land that was changing
beneath our feet over the last five
billion years sorry thought lost five
million years there's been a magma plume
rising up from deep in Earth's interior
and pushing up into the underside of the
continental plates
of Africa it's literally swollen up a
zit on the face of the planet which the
Ethiopian highlands you can see an angry
red spot in the middle of picture there
and that is also caused the skin the
crust of our planet to fracture to tear
and rip open and this very distinctive Y
shaped pattern of the Red Sea running up
here the Gulf of Aden and then the third
arm of this characteristic Y shape
fracturing of the crust is the East
African Rift Valley it's this tunnel and
this fracture in the crust and that's in
that tube in that tunnel where we
evolved and so the rising of the land is
what dried out East Africa turn the
forest and into grassland in Savannah
but what's been puzzling paleontologists
for many many years is what was it
specifically about that fracture in the
earth that drove our evolution to become
so intelligent
what is the environmental question to
which Evolved intelligence is the answer
and what's been emerging in recent years
is that there is this unique interplay
of factors there is the terrain of East
African Rift Valley where you have a hot
low-lying valley floor with towering
mountainous ridges on either side that
any water that does fall in this air is
collected by those valley walls and
funneled down into the Rift Valley floor
where evaporates again very quickly that
distinctive terrain and landscape is
interacting with cosmic cycles war balls
and earth's tilt and orbit around the
Sun and so-called Milankovitch cycles
and those two planetary features have
interacted create this string of lakes
along the valley floor which are
intensely sensitive to even tiny
fluctuations in the rain enos of this
region during periods of of climatic
instability
these lakes have been flickering in and
out of existence like a loose light bulb
flickering on and off and every time
he's late to play and disappear it
greatly changes the availability of
water in there if a lead amount of
vegetation the abundance of animals
which we could hunt it was that chaos
that unpredictability that forced us to
evolve intelligence to be able to out
think on environment to be able to
survive and was plate tectonics and
cosmic cycles that granted us as a
species this thing this incredible
versatility in behavior and intelligence
but although we we grew up in East
Africa we didn't remain here we migrated
and dispersed out of our cradle and came
to inherit the entire world Homo sapiens
is today the most widely dispersed
animal species on the planet and it was
a different period of our planet's
history that enabled us to make that
great migration to inherit the the great
continents of the earth this is what the
planet looks like today this is the the
map you would recognize instantly on the
wall of of any geography school room but
the world 70,000 years ago when we were
migrating Out of Africa did not look
like this completely different this is
how the world looked back then we were
right in the depths of this last great
Ice Age this is only the most recent Ice
Age in a sequence of 40 or 50 ice ages
over the last five or six million years
the world has been an
uncharacteristically chilly period of
its history and during each of these ice
ages these huge glass years and ice
sheets grew mostly on the northern
hemisphere and drew so much water out of
the oceans that the sea levels dropped
by over 100 meters exposed the sea floor
they opened up these land bridges
between the continents the Sunderland
bridge in what is today the archipelago
of East Southeast Asia the Soho
so the Sunderland Bridgend in the Sahul
Ambridge to Australia but most
importantly the human story most
importantly for this part of the world
was the bering land bridge opened up
between Eurasia and the Americas our
ancestors could simply walk without
getting their wheat their feet wet
around the world to colonize and inhabit
all of the corners of the planet and
around 25 20,000 years ago making their
way into North America and then across
the Panama isthmus and down into South
America and as we were dispersing around
the world we encountered some of our
cousin species hominin species from that
evolutionary tree we saw on the first
slide that had migrated out of africa
before us and we then encountered as we
were wandering across the plains of the
earth later you probably heard of the
Neanderthals and we didn't just
encounter his cousin species we got
quite friendly with them as well we
interbred with them people out of Africa
have something like between one and two
percent of Neanderthal DNA in their
genome in your own DNA we also
encountered interbred with an entire
species of humanity the Denisovans that
is only known to us by a few tiny
fragments of finger bone an entire
species of humanity remains today
owning a few tiny shards of finger bone
we should be able to extract out DNA
from sequence it and recognized its
signature in our own genome we migrated
around the world meted with other human
species we encountered and then took
onboard almost like a cargo their DNA
which we then carried with us as we
dispersed but as we walked into the
Americas we were the first human species
ever to make it across and somehow
because we were walking where no human
species had ever trodden before and with
the ending of the last ice age and the
rising of the water levels again these
two great land masses became severed
separated from each other and we began
this great experimental history two
independent experiments and civilization
and in the Eurasia and the Americas
peoples that had the same intelligence
but genetically basically identical we
had access to wild animal and plant
species we could try domesticating
trying our hand at agriculture and is
about 15 20 thousand years later when
some European descendents of those
original migrants took the shortcut the
Americas which to cross the Atlantic and
then was then the the collision of these
two cultures these two civilizations
again the first civilizations to rise as
we dispersed around the world and
happened very very quickly after the
ending that last ice age that that
interglacial period was the first time
that we as a species had encountered an
interglacial the period between ice ages
when we were not in africa who else were
around the world and our answer that
climactic change was to invent
agriculture we domesticated plant
species to feed ourselves we settle down
into increasingly dense populations
until cities emerged and an civilization
grew out of that
and the first civilization to rise in
Eurasia did so here in the Arabian
Peninsula we've talked already about the
opening up of the great East African
Rift Valley and the Red Sea and the Gulf
of Aden here but fracturing of the crust
effectively ripped off a corner of
africa to become the arabian peninsula
but then is the Red Sea continuing to
expand as a newly formed ocean the
entire chunk of crust has been swinging
outwards like a barn door caught in the
wind and it slammed into the underside
of Eurasia and when continents slamming
to each other you crumple up great
mountain ranges the Alps Himalayas in
this case the Zagros mountain range and
running perfectly parallel along the
feet of the Zagros Mountains
is Mesopotamia the cradle of
civilization and what's going on here
and in terms of the tectonic processes
is that whenever you have a newly formed
mountain wings like the Zagros just the
sheer bulk of all of that rock sits
heavy on across the planet and it sags
downwards you get a tectonic trough
running alongside a mountain what a
geologist would call a a for land basin
and these twin rivers of the
tigris-euphrates flow down that tectonic
trough this kind of makes sense right
rivers flow downhill thanks to this but
because these rivers are flowing down
from very fresh young mountain ranges
the sediment llave eroded out and
deposit further downstream is incredibly
rich nutrient rich it gives a very silty
alluvial soil which is fantastically
fertile for growing crops in when you're
still trying to work out agriculture in
the first place and the Mesopotamia that
the land between the rivers very soon
became the land of cities of brook
erosion later
Babylon it is this tectonic process
it's crumpling of the land from the
continental collision that simply
created the ideal conditions under which
early agriculture could yield the first
cities and the first civilization here
in the epic Mesopotamia not only to
plate tectonics creators of species it
gifted us civilization as well and while
this was happening in this part of the
world leading up to around 3,000 BC on
the other side of the planet around
India in exactly the same tectonic
setting the for land basin sagging down
in the feet of the Himalayan mountain
chain the indus valley civilization
emerged different part of the world same
timing in history identical tectonic
setting this is a general theme the
early civilizations to have merged
now civilization spread out of
Mesopotamia and
soon enough reached to the Mediterranean
to this oval-shaped Inland Sea and
perhaps the Mediterranean and the
cultures and societies and civilizations
and empires that bubbled and fizzed
around here are familiar to many of us
from history lessons from watching
documentaries on TV we know of the
Mycenae ins the Phoenicians the
Etruscans the Romans and the nature
Greeks these are cultures that all seem
familiar to us but when you think about
it all of these civilizations from the
beginning of the Bronze Age through
classical era through antiquity almost
without exception they physicist and and
buzzed along the northern half of the
met rhenium sea whereas the southern
half the northern coastline has been
historically very quiet
apart from ancient Egypt this tiny
sliver of a civilization huddled along
the linear Oasis or the River Nile and
Carthage is the other main exception
that exists just on that tiny pinch
there there and came to challenge even
the might of the Romans before they were
crushed and absolutely obliterated they
were literally robbed off the surface of
the earth by that by the Roman armies
all of that activity of history has been
on the northern half not the southern
half there is this grand theme or trend
that's continued for hundreds and
thousands years of history which doesn't
make much sense
until we look at where the Mediterranean
itself has come from where was the
Mediterranean born and it turns out the
Mediterranean that we know of today is
no more than this tiny puddle a remnant
of a once vast ocean then it's hey
heyday was bigger or as big as the
Atlantic Ocean it's the Tethys with
Tati's ocean and if you win back the
history of our own planet to almost
quarter of a billion years ago
this is the map of how our world looked
240 million years ago back then if we
rewind this videotape of our planet's
history and the continents cutting
around across the surface in this period
of history they'd all collided together
and fused into a single giant landmass a
supercontinent called Pangea the all
land and he'll just nur in the cup of
that c-shaped supercontinent was the
Tethys ocean which over time grew and
expanded as the atlantic is is doing
right now until Pangaea ripped itself
tore itself apart again and Africa and
then India rode back north to Rica lied
to back end and this kind of pile up on
the motorway of Earth's continents
closing up the Thames as they went
destroying the ancient ocean swallowing
it back down into the interior of their
planet it's about 15 million years ago
this great ocean of the Tethys now
exists as no more than a narrow Seaway
and so it was closed off at both ends
and now exists is no more than the
puddle of Atlantic and it's that fact
the history of potassium Mediterranean
that explains that grand theme through
our human history the because it is
Africa that is riding north and
colliding into Eurasia
it's crumpled up all that northern
coastline into the Alps Carpathians the
Caucasians this is a crumpled rippled
landscape and with the rising of the sea
levels since the end of the last ice age
is now become a drowned submerged
landscape the northern Mediterranean is
absolutely riddled with natural inlets
and coves and bays and therefore natural
harbors it is perfectly set up perfectly
conducive for seafaring societies for
trading and communicating with each
other by ships whereas the southern half
Mediterranean the African coastline is
flat and straight and
boring it has no natural harbors apart
from Carthage wrong button Lewis idiots
apart from Carthage here which as you
can see is actually just on the lip of
effectively a subterranean mountain
submarine mountain range linking the toe
Avista that is about the only place you
can find a natural harbour in a thousand
miles of coastline around here and so
it's that that explains this great
disparity for thousands of years of
human history it is bestowed it is
created by the history of the
Mediterranean and these planetary forces
now once the fast-forwards
in the talked to a slightly later
chapter of human history and
coincidentally a slightly later chapter
the book which I'm trying to flog to you
tonight and which is looking at how and
the beginnings of the age of sail the
age of discovery when Europe first
started looking out into the wider world
and then came to discover it and push
out and how that was controlled and
dictated by the pattern of winds around
the world that the atmospheric dynamics
and this global wind machine and this
map here might seems like confusing at
first when you look at it I'm trying to
show in this map not the landscape of
the continents but the geography of the
Seas itself so here we've got the bulge
of northwest Africa this is Europe up
here this is the Iberian Peninsula with
what was to become Portugal and then
Spain here and in this period of history
in the early 1400s Europe was a
primitive backwards uncivilized place we
were right on the western extremity of
this broad sprawling continent of
Eurasia we're right on the ends the
terminus of the great trade work
networks that spread across the constant
of the Silk Roads transporting not just
silicon and luxury goods but ideas
culture
religions philosophies technologies
spread along the Silk Road and we were
the last in Europe to get them China had
blast furnaces for making iron and steel
a thousand years before they arrived
eventually diffused and percolated to
Europe and when you're at first started
trying to look out into the wider world
we couldn't head east we couldn't
backtrack along those overland routes
the Silk Road that we knew about because
that Peron history there's a very
powerful Islamic empire blocking us
towards the East we had to turn a head
in the opposite direction towards the
west and out into this vast scary
tempestuous expanse of the Atlantic
Ocean and an ocean that people with a
right mind to just avoided going
anywhere near with your ships we'd criss
cross back and forth across this puddle
of the mediterranean we coasted a bit
down the north african coast but we
stayed well clear for depths of the
atlantic and the stepping stones if you
like that first started drawing european
navigators out first the Portuguese and
then the Spanish and the Brits Dutch
French ever almost piling in sooner
later but the first steps were made by
the Portuguese being pulled out into the
stepping stones of Atlantic archipelagos
and this map makes clear that those
archipelagos those islands are no more
than the furry tips of huge submarine
volcanoes the Azores up here are the
volcanoes that make up the mid-atlantic
ridge this despite rent and Earth's
crust the Atlantic is opening up and the
Portuguese first started heading down
the North African coast following the
direction the winds and the ocean
currents already blowing and then they
hit a fundamental problem if you're used
to coasting heading down along the
familiar safety of the coast and using
landmarks to navigate by how'd you get
back home you can't just turn your ship
around and head back up the way you came
to be floating it the very winds and
ocean currents that took you there in
the first place and the realization
something that must have seemed
completely counterintuitive at the time
is the way to get back home is to turn
away from the safety of the land of the
coast and head deeper out in theack it's
complete what's known as a Volta dome ah
a return of the sea heads out deeper
into the ocean until you pick up a
different set of winds and ocean
currents and when they headed further
down the African coast and then
completes a wider vaulted remar to head
back they discovered the Azores these
islands were completely uninhabited by
humans before this point and what the
Portuguese were doing in these very
first tentative steps out and the deep
ocean were piecing together these jigsaw
pieces of the global picture the global
pattern of where the winds blow and the
structure the predictable patterns about
where the wind bands are and the ocean
currents they blow around and we've
complete that picture now over the over
the subsequent hundreds of years since
then to map out how the atmosphere the
air high above our heads churns around
the planet to create these winds that we
used to trade by and then again this
makes common sense this is intuitive to
a certain extent around the equator
where it's very sunny the warm the air
the warm air rises dumps or terrain
that's why we find the rainforests there
circulates round a very high altitude
before descending back towards the
surface at around 30 degrees north and
south that dry descending air creates
all of the deserts around the planet and
then to complete that great vertical
circulation current the atmosphere has
to return to the equator back along the
ground and that's just what we call the
winds and the only other fact that's
important is that the planet is turning
beneath its own atmosphere as you have
this great circulation currency crates
Coriolis effect to deflect those winds
to one side so either side of the
equator you have these wide bands of
winds always blow to the west the trade
winds
in the next atmospheric circulation
current it creates winds that blow in
the opposite direction the westerlies
there are these conveyor belts wrapped
around the planet that give you
prevailing winds in opposite directions
if you want to navigate across an ocean
between continents to trade and then
come back again once you've worked out
this trick it's a simple method of
hopping back and forth between these
different conveyor belts to take you
back and forth the way you want to go
and we apply that understanding that
global picture of how our atmosphere
works to build some of the longest range
trade routes of history which came to
determine the early stage of
globalization and the building of the
modern world that we live in today
the Portuguese completed their dream of
heading south finding the bottom tip of
Africa reaching Indian Ocean and then
the riches of the Spice Islands which
which they came to monopolize they found
their way of literally circumnavigating
sailing around the Islamic empire up
here to dominate that spice trade
themselves and if you want to sail
around the southern tip of Africa the
only way you can do that but the way
that winds blow is to steer such a wide
loop through the ocean be basically
stumble across Brazil
the reason Brazil speaks Portuguese
whereas the whole rest of South America
speaks Spanish that's just the way the
wind blows people trying to get around
Africa the Spanish first to Columbus
crossed Atlantic stumbled inconvenience
this content have no right to be there
they cut across that new continent and
became the first eyes first European
eyes to see this whole new ocean the
peaceful ocean the Pacific and the
Spanish then established the longest
range trade routes of the age of sail
which is the Spanish Manila galleon
route and they picked up all their trade
goods from China sailed north to round
the coastline of Japan so they could
pick up the band of westerly winds that
bore them the entire breadth the Pacific
to North America where they have been
coast bow
to their silver mines in Mexico because
this time China valued silver even more
than it valued gold loaded up their
ships with that precious metal and then
allowed the trade winds to blow them all
the way back again the reason that
California the reason that where we are
right now and cities like San Francisco
and Los Angeles and San Diego were
founded in the first place is to
resupply those Spanish galleons because
the only place you can get to on the
north african coast after crossing
pacific is here it's just the way the
winds blow around the planet the
portuguese discovered a shortcut across
the Indian Ocean to then Alice the
Portuguese and dominate the spice trade
themselves and by exploiting the band of
winds known as the Roaring Forties the
westerly winds in the southern
hemisphere don't encounter any big
consonants most the contents from the
northern half of the world there are no
mountain range there are no walls to
block those winds and they get stronger
and stronger and stronger the Roaring
Forties are a literal Highway in the
ocean you can shave off weeks of the
crossing time Australia was discovered
by Dutch on this Dutch captain's on this
Brauer routes the short cross a short
cut across the Indian Ocean the problem
with using that highway notion is you
need to know when to take your turn off
from that highway from that freeway if
you miss your turn off you plow into
Australia you wouldn't believe the
number of times captains have
accidentally driven and it's straight
into the side of a continent the the
coastline the coral reefs on the west
side of Australia absolutely littered
with shipwrecks where captains missed
their turn off from the Roaring Forties
from that Highway in the sea the reason
that South Africa became so important
and speaks Afrikaans is that's what you
need to launch your ships from to cross
the Indian Ocean that's why the Dutch
cared about the southern tip of Africa
so much but arguably the most important
trade routes of the subsequent playing
out of history was the North Atlantic
trade triangle this was established at
the beginning of Industrial Revolution
when Britain North yer
had worked out how to get machines to
make things I think to rely on
craftspeople but very very cheaply very
very quickly manufacturing things with
machinery and those manufactured
products textiles weapons were sale down
the old Portuguese route to the north
african coast sold there and then a
ship's hold were filled with slave labor
people kidnapped from their homelands
bundled and chains and to hold these
ships taken across that trade winds
banned the colonies of North Africa but
also South North America but also South
America and then forced to work on the
plantations growing raw plant materials
tea coffee sugar cotton and those raw
materials were then taken along the
Weslie banda winds backed to north
europe where they were converted by
using our machinery into the textiles in
the cloths which we could then trade
back down to north africa and so on and
so on the North Atlantic trade triangle
was an economic cog sat across the ocean
being blown round and round by that
global wind machine and generating huge
profits for its masters for its slave
masters and all of this story of his
building of these vast trade routes are
dictated by where the wind blows these
wind bands specify where you put your
trade routes and therefore way you need
your ports where you put your fortresses
the entire pattern of European expansion
and colonialism and empire building and
the beginnings of globalization made the
modern world was dictated by the
atmospheric dynamics and then in these
wind bands the last story I wanted to
tell you it's all about how you can see
even the fingerprint of the planetary in
politics in in the way that people
choose to vote has a planetary influence
behind it an example I wants to give you
of this is from the United States from
southern States of America and again if
I strip off
the satellite map and instead show you
the political map this is how people
voted in the last presidential election
this what put Trump next the big red
button and unsurprising to you guys
maybe more so in than the UK the
southern states on the whole Republican
era it is a sea of red in this political
map some counties did however vote for
Democrats but the Democrat voting
counties are not spread randomly they're
not scattered across the southern states
there is structure there's a pattern to
where people chose to vote for Democrats
up and down the banks of the Mississippi
here but more curiously along this great
arc this crescent of Democrat voting
counties through the southern states
that doesn't correspond with anything on
the ground anything in the actual
landscape these are the Appalachian
Mountains here these were crumbled up by
the last cycle of continent building
that's what greeted North America as a
continent and that Democratic present
doesn't correspond to anything on the
terrain on the landscape and if we peel
off the landscape map and now I show you
a geological map the dark regions here
are rocks beneath your feet that are 75
to 80 million years old and if I now a
layer on top again the political map
you'll see they will see there's a
striking correspondence between people
choosing to vote Democrats and having
rocks beneath their feet which 80
million years old this makes no sense at
all people are not going to their
backyards drilling bore holes are going
back it's 50 million years old rocks I
want to vote for Hillary but now I've
got a vote for Trump so there's not a
direct link clearly between the geology
and they and people's votes but there is
this wonderful chain of cause and effect
through hundreds of years of human
history and then millions of years of
our planet's history and what was
happening
planet 75 to 18 million years ago in a
chapter of Earth's history called the
Cretaceous is the sea levels were much
much higher back then
the ocean lapped right up through the
middle of North America and a great
interior sea and laid down what was
essentially thick deposits of sea floor
mud which became compacted down buried
by more recent structure of rocks and
then eroded away again and exposed along
this particular arc in the southern
states to the north are rocks older to
the south they're younger these are the
Cretaceous age rocks and when that
rocker roads to create soil it gives you
a very rich fertile dark soil and is
realized in the early 1800s that that
soil is phenomenally productive a
growing cash crops like cotton which as
we've already mentioned unfortunately
this period of history meant slave labor
cotton is incredibly finicky to harvest
it's not like cotton or rice we can
simply chop it off at the stalk take it
out of your field and then shake a bit
to get the grain that you want cotton
requires fingers and even today after
hundreds of years of after the Civil War
and emancipation and freedom from
slavery in the civil rights movement
even today is that Cretaceous band of
rocks that has the highest density of
black African Americans living there
today people unfortunately still suffer
still have blighted with social economic
problems of poor wages poor health care
poor social structures people that are
therefore more likely to vote for
Democrats election promises rather than
Republican and in fact the city I've
marked here Montgomery is where 1955
Rosa Parks refused to give up her seat
to white gentlemen on the bus the very
epicenter of the entire civil rights
movement the transformed Society in
politics at the whole of the United
States began smack in the middle of
rocks at 18 million years old on the
surface and just to demonstrate that I'm
not cherry-picking the only example on
the earth where you do have such a close
correspondence between the geological
and the human and the political
this is an example from my own home
island britain on the left here this the
distribution of constituencies voting
for labour which the main left liberal
political party in the UK in the last
election but pretty much any election
you care to check and on the right in
red is distribution of rocks beneath
your feet
they're about 320 million years old and
again there is a astonishing
astonishingly close correspondence
between those two maps now give you a
hint as to what is behind this the
chapter on Earth's history 320 million
years ago was the Carboniferous these
are the coal deposits something broke
down on planet earth 320 years ago and
broke the planets recycling system trees
grow grew back then very very vigorously
fell over died and would just not rot
for millions of years trees grew but
would not rot and built up these vast
strata of what was effectively
fossilized sunshine subterranean forests
the first in Britain and then Europe and
the rest the world we realized we could
mine to throne our furnaces to power
ourselves with industrial ushion and
even today coal makes up a huge fraction
of our energy use and the last step on
that chain of cause and effect and this
particular correspondence is that the
Labour political party grew up out of
labor unions coal mining unions and the
UK now those are the stories I've had
time to talk about at tonight like I've
just picked out a couple of threads from
origins from the book that I felt I was
most surprised by when I was researching
for this book I put up some other
stories from the base of the clickbait
from origins and it's everything from
wider most of us eat a bowl of cereal or
a slice of toast for breakfast how does
the planet's history
determine even what we eat for breakfast
why is it that Holland and it's drowned
landscape since the last ice age create
the modern financial system why does
capitalist
come out of Holland rather than anywhere
else why is the Great Wall of China
following ecological contour along the
planet and we do have some time for
questions now oh that there's books
available did I mention I have left my
fair isles and put myself on the road
for most this month to try to flog books
to you origins is here if you want to go
on the interweb you can buy a copy of
the knowledge which is my last book we
mentioned was a how to reboot
civilization after an apocalypse maybe
by that in the next couple of months
just to be just to be safe I think we
were going to do a bit of oh yeah
rapturous applause thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much Louis I
think what's really interesting having
marshals talk so recently that kind of
so much of the same conclusions coming
from such a different perspective and I
super appreciate it but not on a
repetitive saying anyway no examples but
I think what's interesting about it is
how much it kind of proves proves the
point and I think it's curious that
these books came out in the same year
yeah it's kind of stunning in a way but
before we get to all the questions I
wanted to answer the question that I
that I know we're all thinking is why
did where were you growing up in the
Rift Valley ah
so in terms of these chains of cause and
effect the proximate cause was my dad
got sent out that he was an engineer for
British Airways he used to tease him
went before he retired that he would
basically pump up the tires and fulham
up the petrol and he was just a
glorified car mechanic which the certain
extent was true until a jumbo jet would
land and it's you know engine would fall
off and there would be like an 18 hour
certain like mechanical surgical
procedure of putting this entire turbo
jet turbo fan engine back onto the wing
of an aircraft and connect all
hydraulics in the fuel so it doesn't
fail at 35,000 feet so I was almost born
in Saudi Arabia when that was post there
but my totally is in Dubai and was out
to school in in Nairobi the publishers
were really trying to push hard on that
kind of make more of a new publicity
that you grew up in my robe and you had
this yearning for your entire life to
understand only your own origins but the
origins of your speeches I mean I could
but people see through that kind of [ __ ]
quite quickly right I think about how
your study of astrobiology kind of
informs this book of you know are you
are you looking at the geology of Mars
and
the moons of Jupiter and Saturn for
their geology to figure where you you
know where is the Rift Valley of Mars is
that a in a sense in a sense but Mars
has no RIF Ally at all Mars has no
evidence for plate tectonics and it does
have a valence Marineris a huge kind of
fraction across this different process
going on there and and although
geologists not me I'm I'm actually a
biologist I've been faking a lot of this
earth science here
people who study Mars try to understand
Mars as history by the geological signs
we can see on the surface today and
therefore where is the best place to
land our Rover to look for signs of life
but actually what I kind of brought
origins wasn't so much that kind of
astrobiology angle but just coming at
this big history topic as an
inter-district being kind of comfortable
Outlaw kind of willing to go out of my
comfort zone and teach himself a lot of
science and planetary science and an
astrophysics and sort of things I talk
about and try to fuse them all together
to look and find these grand themes and
trends in history for the book so it was
less about finding aliens for this one
life in universe it was my book I wrote
and in fact that one called aliens those
are books by aliens it literally says
what it does what it says on the tin and
know that this was origins was the book
that's taken me far longest to research
and right out of out of all my books
I've written because it's that much
further from I kind of home discipline
if you like I mean not just origins of
species or potential species on other
planets but what about extinctions is
that like reasons for extinctions and I
mean I know that there's supposition
about why Mars atmosphere has gone away
and basically why life might have
stopped there is that also part of your
study yes so Mars is interesting it's
it's our next-door name of planets and
in many respects the most earth-like
place we know about or at least it used
to be we see substantial evidence that
used to have rivers and oceans and lakes
of liquid water on its surface and watch
their atmosphere but it suffered this
kind of global catastrophic collapse the
magnetic field
elderly on Mars atmospheres being blown
away into space it's now dried up on the
surface to become a kind of freezing
cold desert so if life did get started
on a warmer wetter Mars and a primordial
Mars and it's there still today it's
almost certainly extinct or its kind the
relics of the life we'll be looking for
so looking flyff on Mars isn't looking
for green bug-eyed monsters it's
probably not even looking for alive
cells it's looking for fossilized cells
or the kind of chemical relics after
that and so that's what our Mars rovers
do that they're basically militarized
laboratories with some wheels on the
bottom and some solar panels on top and
a camera or two so we can see what we're
going to study in situ Mars to look for
interesting organic chemistry well and
before we go to questions from the
audience and we have you're gonna be
giving out the mic so wave your hands to
our lovely volunteer and you will get a
mic into your hand as we move forward
the the part of your book that really I
listen to your book on the way back from
Burning Man last week so it was kind of
this great tour of geology as I crossed
that I came across the geology in
California kind of where of one of the
places at least we're kind of that the
the people across the land bridge stop
first and it was it was amazing in that
right but the the part where they
figured out this thing and the
Tradewinds to turn away from turn away
from the safety of land what I didn't
get is do we have do we have records of
you know who was who was the first
jackass you did that I mean I think they
realized that the winds were against
them further north yeah and from the
coast and then so they had to go find
those but also the kind of Christopher
Columbus story of like how did he know
he was gonna get back so it's a Columbus
basically cheated no one was gonna fund
Columbus the Portuguese certainly
weren't because by that point there the
Portuguese navigators are about to
around the tip of South African they
thought they had a route into the Spice
Islands anyway so this genu is navigator
Club and you can almost certainly
imagine Columbus where this kind of like
rude boys swagger going I can gauge the
spot
silence and he fudged the numbers
because if you take the numbers but
known at the time for the size of the
earth and the known distance from Europe
to India and China across land because
we had those measurements from the from
Silk Roads there is no way a ship could
ever have survived if the ocean was
there all the way around so Columbus was
a lucky sod in the happen to be a
continent in the way but he stumbled
into to go today I told you guys all
along died without accepting that he'd
not discovered a route to India and
found this kind of whole new land but
Columbus cheated by faintly exploiting
that Portuguese knowledge of the vault
Domar you can't go back where you came
from the way you got there you have to
go north or south to reach that kind of
app losing band and takeaway back across
and this is really interesting quirk of
history but if Columbus had been
sponsored by the Portuguese I'll show
you the map because it makes a lot of
sense if port if Columbus had been
sponsored by the Portuguese he would
have begun his transatlantic crossing
attempt computers and from not the
Canary Islands but the Azores Canary
Islands were owned by the Spanish by
treaty there's also owned by the
Portuguese and the Azores we now know a
third of the way across the Atlantic
towards the America it would have been
the natural place to attempt a crossing
of the sea get as far out as you can be
or notice from the wind bands that you
would be fighting the winds we in the
Iowa see you so if the Portuguese had
supported him Columbus who had died deep
in Atlantic because he was putting
himself on the wrong wind ban it was
through sheer fluke the Spanish ended up
supporting him every started in the
Canary Islands and effectively to
allowed himself to be blown downwind the
whole way as he stumbled into the
Caribbean and the rest they say is is
history was that quirk
but I think with many things if Columbus
hadn't done it someone would have done
it within maybe 10 20 years often things
in history kind of have their time you
know we now know that the Vikings were
crossing further north and what
a little version of that circle was I
assumed they were taking advantage of
trade winds up there as well yeah it
would be beyond the Weslie winds is
another band of West V blowing winds
that the North's were able to go but
during a period of Earth's climatic
history called the Medieval Warm so
Greenland was Green back then and they
able to colonize new from Newfoundland
simply because the earth was warmer in
that period of kind of pre pre modern
history cool alright we have our first
question somebody with a mic nope I
think that was a great talk and I
realize that you have abbreviated that
you have much more detailed in the book
itself the Rift Valley and is evolving
into having a larger brain that to me
demonstrates a correlation but not a
cause-and-effect and I wonder whether
you have more evidence in your book on
that point and yes is the short answer
the longer answer is there's something
like 600 references in the back of the
book that will make your eyes bleed if
you wanted to read into into all the
detail behind this but I cede your point
in general that correlation does not
necessarily mean causation and you need
mechanisms to explain things which you
can corroborate with evidence and kind
of supporting data but it stands out
starkly when you put on a kind of time
line these periods of extreme climactic
instability in the East African Rift
Valley from these cosmic cycles and
their language cycles and the emergence
points of new homonym species or jumps
in cranial capacity in the fossil record
all the emergence of new stone
technologies they all cluster very
tightly in those distinct periods of
climactic Milankovitch cycles just to
review my understanding is that it's the
the wobble and the Earth's axis which is
about every 26,000 years
a procession here procession of the
equinoxes there are three major ones and
to do with the evilness all circular
miss of Earth's orbit around the Sun and
then the precession of the Earth's axis
from the equinoxes but also the axial
tilt the three moons they were putting
abundance in the environment every fifty
two thousand years and then kind of
struggles into the environment on the
opposite sides of those circles yeah
exactly during and the the main one was
driven by the precession cycle which is
the shortest one and during periods of
instability and then driven by the
precession cycle getting a bit too much
detail now and but those that was the
times when those amplify lakes are
called wrath occurring in and out and
importantly changing environment on a
time course shorter than the lifespan of
an individual because if it just gets
dry around you you evolve a camel that
that's happened plenty place that's easy
to evolve a solution to if you
environment is going wet dry wet dry wet
dry you can't evolve your body to
survive you've got to change you build a
tool you build a brain that can out
think the environment that that's the
idea behind our intelligence because
because our big brains for normally
expensive things to support an x amount
of food we have to eat to provide them
Nick alright thank you you have another
question
well thank you very much for the talk
has a lot of wonderful information when
I saw the diagram of the wind patterns
organized into those bubbles around the
globe
I was curious why the chirality reverses
at 30 degrees why it's organized into
six distinct sections rather than eight
or ten or two firstly I'll salute your
usage of chirality
I enjoyed that events Corral she's got
who's got a lot of usage in astrobiology
because it determines where the
molecules are like left-handed
right-handed it's one of the signatures
we look for life is the chirality of
molecules but to answer your question
those Hadley cells are heat engines
convection cell just like you get over a
radiator where warm air rises and then
sinks in this vertical sell the Farrell
cell
sorry the polar cells although you're
much higher latitudes and it's cooler
there is still enough rising and then
sinking again of the air masses to
create a circulation current for the
same sense the same chirality as the
Hadley cell and in between the two is
the Farrell cell which is a passive
circulation system you've got two cogs
turning on both sides in the same
direction which then turns the cog in
the middle Farrell cell is driven by the
Hadley cell and the polar cell so it's
passive but importantly it turns
therefore the opposite direction and
therefore the winds on the surface it
gives you bone off the direction
otherwise exploration would have been
crap if all the winds blew in the same
direction you you would have to
circumnavigate the planet each time you
wanted to trade across an ocean it'd be
rubbish and the terminals like the
rotation rate of the earth the kind of
temperature gradient the atmosphere so
Jupiter's got those circulation currents
credibly visibly in its atmosphere
because they you can see the bands of
kind of orange red orange red the
chemistry of the clouds is different
that really highlights those Hadley
circulation cells and Jupiter's
and satin to a lesser extent because
Jupiter rotate so quickly yeah so we see
that in the gas giants really well yeah
other questions in the back yes so the
diagram showing where and soil that was
older and more nutrient-rich was
predictive of political outcomes are
there other areas in the world where you
haven't yet seen the more pronounced a
little black comes where you predict
that will happen because I soil sorry
are the regions in the world where we
predict I haven't seen yet so we see the
political outcome and then and then we
see the the pattern you needed the
political outcome in order to notice
this pattern are there other parts of
the world where now that we know this
about soil and the aedra soil in the
nutrients of soil are there parts of the
world where we see the the predictive
variable where you have the nutrient
renew trait rich older soil where we
might start to see some emerging
political patterns sorry I see what you
mean um I used this to demonstrate what
I thought was a really satisfying chain
of cause and effect I've said cross
centuries of our history no millions of
years planetary history yeah you would
be brave to try to make predictions on a
single election based on on geology but
we're talk about two very different
timescales here
although the point I was making here is
that pattern persists from one election
to the next it's not random there is a
deeper cause at a strong expansion it's
over the nadir with the fact that you
know we had a strange feature of Labor
that happened with slavery in the United
States or in the case of the UK labor of
minds that that drew short blue collar
workers so it you you would need that
mix of the strange labor infusion so I
mean my central point my central
argument in origins is that historians
have traditionally focused on cultural
explanations social historic economic
and those are all of course important
you would be a fool to argue they're not
important behind history but why I make
things they are the top level proximate
explanations for the course of history
the world we find today and very just
beneath that are the deeper levels of
explain
the geological or planetary the
atmospheric and they are all important
but my point is that often the planetary
causes have been neglected or ignored in
our interpretation and explanations of
history even though they can't always be
predictive because they change slowly
the other thing I love about this map is
if you put the emergence that the start
date of football teams across the UK
they all absolutely crossed onto rocks
which are 320 million years old and
again this makes sense in the nut
revolution you go where the energy is
where the coal fields are that's where
the factories were built that's where
you have that first burst of
urbanization in the cities people get
bored on the weekends when they're not
on factories they invent games and
kicking around inflated pig bladders and
that's now the Premier League and people
diving in the box but it but again it is
slightly more kind of superficial
example but again there's a very close
correlation between the kind of planet
Trin and you could imagine that there's
something like this in South America
around mines and as well as even north
the north west around forests and and
how the people who've been attracted for
that labour may have affected the
politics obviously yeah of those areas
it's maybe a more on a biological level
in a geologic level in some cases yes
countries but Points plenty of similar
examples to entities
are there other questions from the
audience there's this one on the Corning
you might not be able to see your mind
seems really well-trained to like not
see causation and only see correlation
but like what if it wasn't what are some
really good attempting causal
relationships that exist in your
research that you've just had to tell
yourself okay correlation isn't
causation but like what are the work
oh so I teach a class at my university
on use and abuse of statistics and
infographics which I don't quite
understand why becoming so popular
because it's two basic types of
scientist plotting information but
newspapers websites now going crazy of
infographics like blow my mind we can
draw pictures of a beta and all my
favorite correlations is it's something
like
usage of Internet Explorer 4 and the
murder rate and and and I can't quite
remember it but it's it is a correlation
not a causation which we've talked about
already invert over time people have
stopped using tech Explorer 4 because
Mac's are much better anyway and people
use Safari now and the murder rate has
also been decreasing over time because
if you've got better at police forces
and predicting crimes and stuff there's
another cracking one between if you plot
chocolate consumption per capita the
amount of chocolate that people eat in a
country versus number of Nobel Prizes
they've won and there is a dead straight
linear relationship you can do the
r-squared value the correlation
coefficient is basically exactly one
statisticians would tell you yeah that's
ironclad but again often the correlation
is due to two things being determined by
an invisible third thing and in this
case it's clearly the wealth of the
country people who are in better-off
countries have more disposable income
and of course you're going to spend on
beer and chocolate and countries which
are better funded have more money to put
into research and science and their form
mate but also historically countries
which industrialized early have had that
kind of historical based it accumulates
more mobile prizes over time I'm pretty
sure if I do use ie for last question
here in the front I'd like to debate the
use of Safari but actually I've already
forgotten the name of the ocean which
has been tough easy to a part but you
basically described that the
civilizations that bloomed on the
northern edge were blooming because of
the richness what describes the outlier
from the south one of which being Egypt
you know one of the most advanced
ancient civilizations was it just in a
perfectly good spot in an otherwise
tough neighborhood yeah kind of fat so I
didn't mean to be hating on Egyptians I
have a lot of love for them as a
civilization as well they're my top five
civilizations of all history and I do
talk at quite a length about the ancient
Egyptian civilization in origins and I
mentioned briefly during the talk about
how it's this this slither of
civilization
oasis of the nile and actually that
proved to be a great advantage in one
sense for the egyptians because you
don't need to waste much morning you
ain't on an army to defend yourself from
an invasion because environment does
that quite effective for you people
don't march armies across deserts they
really have to the british do yeah okay
we're gonna get all clonal about it but
the flip side of that was also you can't
you don't get much timber to use in a
desert so the egyptians were never able
to build their own navy to spread their
influence further afield
they got cedar from basically lebanon
but i was exceedingly expensive so he
never developed a navy to explore them
and training or come down the Red Sea
into the rest of the world and that's
probably why Egypt had no lasting effect
in history no one else adopted
hieroglyphics we didn't adopt the same
belief system and religion and culture
as Egypt because they kind of kept
themselves because they bottled in by by
the environments by the desert and
there's this whole other the several
other facets that meant Egypt was
perfectly set up to be a flourishing but
limited civilization to do with the
direction the wind and the direction the
the Nile flowed but it was very helpful
for them and I talked about Carthage
which sits right on this little nub here
when you say wind so the wind goes
against the direction of the exactly so
you flow downhill in one direction with
the Nile and then sail back up again and
you've got a natural transit system
which enabled the Old Kingdom to be
unified in the first veronik dynasties
it was that transport system that
enabled them to exert an influence of a
such a wide area so early in history so
Egypt unified around 3,000 BC it's
incredibly early in history to build
such a such an empire of a large spatial
expanse and then Carthage we talked
about is about the only natural harbor
in that entire stretch and that's why
they became so influential through trade
and then challenging Rome which the
Romans didn't like so much they said
enough is nothing and wipe them out
which is a bit mean yeah but those are
pretty much the only two exceptions and
across the southern half of the
Mediterranean
well I want to thank you very much for
joining us tonight thank you
and I think this will be your second
coin but all of our lasers set one of
our challenge coins really thank you
[Applause]
[Music]